ils sont toujours à vous et homosexuels dans
la personne et à tendance homosexuelle
simple
et seulement s'ils n'ont pas vu que cela implique
visiblement vintage
Croyez-vous ou non à un phénomène social ?
l'une des réussites est d'avoir mis en
remettre en question les opinions de quelqu'un a fait seul
l'exigence qu'il fasse quelque chose et je dirai à un
père qui boit c'est son boulot sa filiale
tendance école
J'ai tiré cousin du pliage je croyais
pas avec la victoire
[Musique]
dialogue
casquette
pour l'expansion aux filiales affiliées
pour l'espace parce que
si c'est premier aujourd'hui lequel est si
montre l'inquiétude dans le film
une chose est importante et quand
ils ont manifesté des vins qui sont néanmoins
chose de père
avec la psychiatrie
le vert doit commencer au loin notre
chose lorsqu'elle se manifeste à partir de 90 ans
frais
M'a donné plus que le silence est un
remède et maintenant il a déduit la filia avec
la tendance homosexuelle est une manche de
maternité paternité 26 mon travail à
dire que j'ai rejoint de soto père tu as commencé
maman car je t'aime
J'ai le père mère nom l'abbé
qui t'a plus rejoint dans le milieu
toujours au diable
parce que l'école secondaire a coïncidé averti
à une famille de la famille mettant
Je ne parle jamais des habitudes familiales
coûte plus cher que pour le
paternité et maternité grâce à la
exiger la grâce